most people have contact with the NHS
from the moment they're born they look
after us at Birth and they look after us
at the very end from Cradle to grave so
we're better to talk about the birth of
the NHS 75 years ago than a maternity
ward
I'm Sally Lockwood this is the Sky News
Daily I've just arrived at Whittington
hospital in North London where I'm going
to go and talk to some new mums and
midwives
sure thing
baby start they all join in a chorus
A Chorus of crying I'm on the Celly
award which is the postnatal award here
it's very quiet at the moment and I'm
with Andrew who's showing us around
today he's just told me that there's
been a hospital on this site for more
than 500 years but obviously only in its
NHS form for 75.
knock knock I don't I can't knock on
this blue curtain
hello hi I'm Sally how you doing
yeah congratulations thank you so what
are your names my name is quesy and
who's this this is
a baby for now we haven't got a name yet
yeah we haven't got a name right now
we're still deciding
so yeah it's a little boy oh my goodness
he's beautiful thank you quesy how are
you feeling
happy now
I feel like the whole experience was
very overwhelming I came in so I
prepared myself I relaxed I don't like
breathing techniques I meditated
had like a warm bath like I'd have my
herbal tea really to prepare myself
because I was really scared I didn't
want
to put my baby at risk so I came in
and um
it just went really bad from the
induction to actually having him how
long was that period of time so it was
literally one week because we came in on
the Sunday and he was born on Sunday at
three minutes past 11. question you've
clearly been through quite an ordeal and
it sounds like a lengthy one but you're
you're lying back on on the bed here
looking like you're ready for a magazine
shoot dressed all in white you look
fabulous with your little baby boy next
to you lying on a pillow who's just
gorgeous with a thick head of dark hair
and his little hands covered in his in
his onesie how would you sum up your
birth experience here
I don't know I just feel like it was a
lot to take on
but
with all the Care and
all of the doctors midwives and nurses
they've all been amazing they've all
helped and I'm just really happy and
thankful the doctor he reassured us from
the start he was amazing and the best
doctors ever and he was so nice to even
comment say that he would actually do
the C-section for us but we asked him to
stay we said because how much because he
felt comfortable and he's with him he
said is it would you be possible that
you could stay and he was like yeah like
because we've built like a bond we've
been here for this long he's like yeah
like I want to do it myself who used to
and he actually took the time to stay
and it was like wow like because he
didn't have to do that he could have
just got in his car about my money today
see you later
question mark speak highly of the NHS
staff they've seen but they say they've
noticed rotors are tight and they worry
about the nhs's future which Rings true
with polling about how most of the
British public feel about what will
happen to the Health Service so the
experience was obviously at the start
very very scary
but um overall there are like
a couple of things that
yeah it could do an improvement
improvement I just felt like um
if the
midwives or the doctors
Midwife support on the ward officer
elsewhere in this sort of scenario it's
not the big things that characters the
small little things just someone popping
their head in and just seeing are you
okay how are you feeling today the
Snapback there was one day we got left
for like nine hours no one coming
unchecked or nothing so I said
there wasn't really much communication
so I just said like going forward I like
I do understand that everyone's under
stress and understaffed and that but
just a small little bits to make the
mum's head at ease just pop your head
and then just say how are you today
how's everything do you need a glass of
water do you need this just to make
their life a bit more easier yeah but
that's the only Improvement I would say
but at the same time we do understand
that they are also worked off their feet
yeah and it's really hard for them to
obviously
be in different Wards because they're
such a shortage so yeah I think
communication is very important
yes but all the midwives have been
amazing like all of them have been sent
to them the whole team
yeah that's what it is that's what it
does come down to like all of them have
been they have gone beyond beyond to
coming in helping us and that but as you
said there's just not enough and
if there is young people out there that
would like to be a job that is very
rewarding I would say step into this
because
me being here for this week I've I've
learned a lot myself and I've realized
wow like this is a really really
wonderful job for people to be helpful
with everyone are you kidding you sound
like a pro now maybe you should change
careers
because he told me as a black woman she
was scared about inequality and not
without reason
a report from MPS recently found
maternal deaths are four times higher in
black women compared to white women I
kept saying to my partner that I am
scared
I'm so scared to go for a cesarean
because
I could die but he didn't believe me he
thought that I was like
exaggerating and I explained to him for
some reason sometimes
um
you know black women have a higher
chance of dying through childbirth I've
heard of a few women that have died and
they have been black
um at childbirth and not only the mum
died the baby died too so it was just a
bit frightening
but you think that makes childbirth that
much more scary for black women yeah it
definitely does so I feel like if you do
have like a doctor that can speak to the
mother that is preparing to go to have a
baby for cesarean it's nice for the lady
to be parties and and all the questions
that she once answered answered by the
doctor so she knows exactly what the
steps are going to be when she goes
under the knife or
you know the the pain relief that she's
going to receive the aftercare
was it the war Midwest speaking of how
can I help
the midwives in the postnatal ward are
clearly busy um but we're going to try
and grab a quick word with some of them
so we're just going to hang out by their
desk which has a shelf packed with thank
you cards
my name's Kelly I've been a midwife
Sam's Kobe 2020. oh my goodness what
time to start I know yeah it was to come
in so at the end of my student yes I was
asked to step in and get paid for it as
well because there was no staff due to
covid and all the
and how have you found the job
amazing
I absolutely love it I love being the
advocate for women and their babies it's
just the most amazing job ever what's
your average day here like
well it varies so some days it can be
absolutely lovely and you feel like you
can provide you know
um the amount of care that you want to
and other days it's really Manic and
there's not enough of us to provide that
care when it's an absolute full Ward but
we do like I said try our best to
provide equal care to every woman and
what's that like that that sounds pretty
tough when you have those days it's
really tough and it can drag you you
know down but we've got a really strong
team up here who keep each other going
and we all support each other which is
the most important to us
oh it looks like it's lunchtime on the
NATO award we'll make room for the
trolley
[Music]
I've just come down to the birth center
which is a midwife lead unit it's
different to the labor Ward it's where
women can come to have their babies
either in water there's big bathtubs in
some of the rooms there's also bouncy
balls but essentially it's a midwife-led
experience without medical intervention
if you need any sort of epidural or you
need inducing then that all happens on
the labor Ward we're just going to go
and meet one of the new mums here
Irina
congratulations
and who's who's this little one what's
their name Alexandra Alexandra she is
absolutely tiny
how old is she well she's one day old
is it what it is
gonna be one day
pipes are working well and is this your
first baby it is how did you find the
experience overall it's painful but it's
not as painful as we as I was thinking
at least it was painful
um the most painful part were the
contractions and the pushing and then
once she started coming out it was okay
you just you just want her or him into
your arms and obviously you know you
hear all the time about the NHS
suffering with a staff shortage funding
shortages it didn't it doesn't sound
like you felt that at all in terms of
your experience I didn't feel it no but
I'm sure there are there are some issues
since people talk about it but in terms
of what you experienced here it felt
like what sounds like a gold standard
treatment exactly exactly was absolutely
it was absolutely fantastic
when the actual birth was happening
um because my contractions slowed down
there were maybe four or five people
coming into the room to check and they
were all Consulting and it didn't feel
like there was not enough people at that
moment
and and Irina you're you're from Belarus
and Alessandra you're from Italy
um so obviously you now live in the UK
and you've had your baby here
um what does the NHS mean to you
you know after this experience
um really really good feelings and it it
means security probably it means I trust
it for sure after what I've been through
and how it all went
and of course none of that happens by
magic or by accident I'm sitting in a
huddle with uh two of The Midwives who
work here at the hospital in one of the
um rooms on the in the birth center I'm
on a birthing ball bouncing bouncy
birthing ball to chat to Adina who has
um one Midwife of the year if I'm not
mistaken is that right Regina
and I'm also with Gabriella who's a
trainee student midwife hi Gabriella hi
so let's start with you first Adina how
long have you been a midwife
for about 18 years
um I came to work at wheatington
initially as a staff nurse and every
time I was coming down from my water I
just used to see labor and I'm like I am
definitely going to be a midwife and I
grew in my role as a midwife which I
love very much I love our mothers I love
our babies and now I'm a labeled
um coordinator and this year I won my
long service
at Whittington for serving 15 to 20
years at Whittington Hospital many
babies along the journey it's been an
amazing journey really and Adina in the
20 years that you've been a midwife
how has the birthing experience changed
on the NHS for mothers and for midwives
um I think
the market difference in midrific care
definitely is the years went on
um
the the care has improved quite a lot
obviously there are issues here and
there but
I think our experience has really
brought a lot of changes to to the care
that we deliver in
in general over the years and you know
just listening to you Edina there's
absolutely no doubt that you absolutely
love your job
what are the tough bits about your job
um I think the long hours can be quite
tough especially if you're busy but I
think overallly we really don't
concentrate so much on the hours we're
just concentrating on on the outcomes
that we get at the end of a full day
basically or whether it's a night shift
or a day shift of course you know we've
heard a lot from nurses and NHS staff
they feel undervalued and they're not
paid enough and there's not enough help
there's not enough Staffing there's not
enough resource how much is that
an issue for midwives as well
I think obviously it does have an effect
on us but I think when the last
um strikes we we arranged we didn't take
part which I which um I think it shows
our dedication to our women yes uh pay
is part of
um the whole morale towards you know the
level of care that people deliver and
obviously stuffing is an issue but like
this year
um recently I took part in the
interviews which is to help our our
numbers of Midwest go up and I think
people are positive that it's going to
improve our our morale and obviously the
kid that we we give at the end of it all
but the pay issue it is a big issue with
everyone not always about money but yes
it will be good obviously if if that
area is exploded more so that midwives
are paid better for the services that we
render we hear about Recruitment and
Retention being an issue in almost every
NHS department but Gabriella of course
you've chosen to sign up at very
recently to become a midwife what made
you choose to go into this line of work
with the NHS
as a student you know happens to manage
the day is what pretty smart put a smile
to my face if I feel like I did my job
as a student to help someone and listen
to them I am more happy than that if I
didn't I would feel so bad that I didn't
I would reflect on that and then be like
what should I do to improve or ask the
lady that took care of the mother what
could I improve on to see what I can do
for the next person but in overall every
day is a different day for me to learn
from The Midwives the mom babies anyone
around my calendar from that and then
use it to improve the care that I
provide well certainly sitting here
bouncing on a birthing ball and looking
at this massive uh birthing pool in in
the private room with you as Midwife of
the Year Adina certainly I think you
know most people would opt for this
experience with you if they could if
they were gonna have a baby but of
course so many people don't have have
all of that on hand and you do you do
hear there have been various scandals
when it comes to other maternity units
around the country
with the depth of experience that you
have as a midwife when you read about
these scandals
um and hear about them what's your
Takeaway on what's going wrong
I think it's scary yes definitely
um
but it makes you think and reflect on
every day on the kid that you deliver
you're like okay let's aim and let's um
fight to give the best Safe Care that we
can because no one wants to find
themselves in that situation whereby
they are
your hospital your maternity unit is in
the headlines just for the wrong reasons
and also it's
scary for the women knowing oh my God my
care is going to be delivered it's this
place which is unsafe so for us
I think it moves you more towards being
a very safe practitioner and being extra
cautious when you deliver care and you
know just trying to give your hundred
percent you know level of care just to
prevent all these
um mishaps incidents is happening
do you feel that you have everything you
need to give the care that you want to
your patients and if not what do you
want in order for the NHS to be the best
it can be in the future
certainly stuffing is a big thing at the
moment it's it is a big thing and
as long as we do have more stuff we do
have the numbers that we need for every
shift then we we are guaranteed to
deliver safe care that's that's one and
certainly also people are able to
to work with smiles you know on their
faces because they are not pressurized
too much so because sometimes we are
stressed because like maternity
Midwifery is very unpredictable so you
don't know who's coming what's coming
next and obviously if you're poorly
stuffed then it has an impact on on
people's morale and
then it
becomes unsafe for us to give the high
level of care that we need and obviously
with more funding into our NHS into our
maternity units then we are able to have
the right equipment we're ever able to
have enough equipment that we need we're
able to have more modernized maternity
units and that will help the women also
to to achieve the the level of care that
they expect from the NHS which at the
moment yes we do try but obviously
there's always those at the moment
Staffing is a big thing and it has an
impact on the care that we finally
deliver sometimes
and Gabriella you're very much the
future of the NHS a future Midwife of
the year in the making I'm sure
um what do you want for the NHS in the
next 75 years
a place where everyone's appreciated
more and more each shift which is not
not I'm saying that no one's appreciated
everyone here is appreciative for the
good works they do and I just didn't I
see it and it makes me want to be more
and more like that where I don't want to
come into work feeling like oh there's
another shift I want to come into work
saying yes another baby's coming on the
way and Mum is here to deliver we will
do this safely and hopefully Super
Saiyan
well one of the reasons we're talking
about maternity today is it's a
department in the NHS that has been in
the headlines a lot over the last few
years and not always for good reason
last year there was the ochendon review
that found catastrophic failings at
Shrewsbury in Telford NHS trust led to
the deaths of more than 200 babies and
nine mothers over a 20-year period until
as recently as 2019.
Stephanie snow has written about 75
years of the NHS and knows a thing or
two about Midwifery she's even a
consultant on the TV show called midwife
well before the NHS a lot of babies
would be born at home
mothers would have to pay for a midwife
or a doctor to attend and so yet in some
circumstances they relied on local
people to support them and birth was
very much a home Affair and these local
people very often local women who would
help other women with childbirth weren't
necessarily always trained they just
happen to be the best person with the
most knowledge in the local area yes I
mean Healthcare at that point could be
very much what was described as make do
and mend you know so people who had
knowledge who'd sort of built up a bit
of experience through helping others you
know there would often be someone in a
village or a town that people would go
to when they had health concerns and
obviously birth was one of those of
course we know that nurses and midwives
in the NHS do a wonderful job but
the NHS of course isn't without its
problems and there have been a number of
scandals over the years when it comes to
maternity units
do you think that women and babies are
more at risk now due to staffing issues
and funding issues within the NHS
I think one of the things that is
consistent in what women appreciate and
find makes the most difference across
the generations is continuity of care
from the caregivers so you know
particularly in birth during the sort of
antenatal care during labor and
childbirth itself the thing that women
see is making the most different is
actually having a strong emotional
connection with the midwives and other
staff who are looking for you know
looking after them so obviously you know
at the moment we know the NHS is really
struggling with these enormous Workforce
shortages
which apply across all services and so
yes you know this is definitely going to
affect women's experience of birth I
mean another major concern now there is
growing evidence that there are
inequalities in health outcomes between
different groups with different ethnic
heritages and you know there have been
recent reports which really established
that the outcomes between white women
and brown and black women they have
worse experience there's worse outcomes
um you know and this is this is
something that we just can't tolerate we
do need to address that what's needed
what's needed to improve things
you know when it comes to that
Healthcare and Equity when it comes to
race but also when it comes to safety
for mothers and babies I mean I think
the good thing is that
um last summer July 2020 we did have the
Women's Health strategy
published and that acknowledged that
there had been long neglect of women's
health including birth so I think having
had that now and also all the evidence
that has come from the covid-19 pandemic
about the disproportionist
impact of covid on communities and NHS
staff with sort of ethnic Heritage again
I think it's one of those major issues
going forwards and it will rely on
Workforce shortages being addressed and
many more deep conversations between
women and caregivers to make sure that
women's voices are at the center of
Health policy and practice change
as someone who's studied about and
written about the NHS in great detail
where do you see the NHS in five years
time of course there's lots of
speculation about
Healthcare being privatized in the UK
the NHS has a history of sort of crises
you know through the different decades
um I mean I would say from the
information that we have the feedback
we've had from our interviewees there is
it's still a strong and persistent
public commitment to the vision of the
National Health Service as a service
which can provide care for everybody
regardless of their ability to pay but
you know the NHS has got a lot of solid
um you know Improvement history behind
it that can take it forward to a
positive future
time for us to go now everyone here is
super busy lots of babies to birth but
on the 75th anniversary of the NHS my
thanks to everyone at Whittington
hospital and to Stephanie snow and to
you for listening to the Sky News Daily
with me Sally Lockwood this episode was
produced by Emma Ray Woodhouse with Alex
edin the editor was Paul sandworth